filip bump joins us he's a national
correspondent for the Washington Post
Phillip good morning as as Nicole said
there it looks unlikely that this that
an override will occurred correct yeah
yeah that's right
I mean two-thirds majority in the House
by itself requires you know something
like 100 Republicans to come on board
it's not quite that many but it's
unlikely to happen another eight in the
Senate it's it's an uphill climb so
where does this go from here then well I
mean the the most natural place is gonna
go next is to the courts it's very
likely it's gonna face legal challenges
potentially from Congress this idea of
using this emergency declaration this
way it's certainly going to face a legal
challenge from people whose land will
need to be seized in order to build the
wall there's gonna be tons venneman
eminent domain fights actually looked at
this about a month ago in 2006 they
passed a bill to expand the wall they're
still I mean it don't mean fights going
on from that so this thing's not going
up anytime soon
one of the things we've seen this week
federal work got in the race as far as
the presidential race on the Democratic
side before we talk about beto why are
we seeing so many in this race so early
yeah it's fact I mean if you look at
four years ago there were literally no
major party candidates in the race at
this point four years ago part of it I
think is simply because everyone else is
jumping in people want to get part of
the conversation they you know it's sort
of a herd mentality part of the to is
the Democrats set a standard if you can
get 65,000 contributions before the
first debate you can be in the debate
and for some candidates that's gonna
take a lot of work it's gonna take some
time so they're getting in early to
start building those contributions we
have dad though what's taking Joe Biden
so long that's a fair question I think
one of the things that Biden has is he
has the advantage of being a
front-runner coming out of the gate so
he doesn't need to build that same sort
of name identity the same sort of base
of people who might be supporting him he
has that advantage and I think he also
likes the fact we're saying you're
talking about him because he's not in
racing if there a deadline for him and
you think at this at the point at which
he probably doesn't want to go past in
terms of making this decision well I
think the I don't really think so I mean
I think the first debates in June I mean
he obviously wants to be on that debate
stage but he I mean Donald Trump they
meant to the race until mid-june 2015
either and turned out okay for him the
better will work obviously comes with a
more centrist message compared to some
of the other candidates out there but
they're also questions about his
experience right now yeah yeah that's
exactly right I mean I think that the
the the message of the he sort of
leading with is the message of I am a
fresh face in this field and I think
that's something we've seen be added
just in the past he's coming a sort of a
blank slate I mean yes he in the past
has had sort of centrist record he's
also offering a lot of the same sort of
progressive messages you've heard from
other candidates I think he is
recognizing he has an advantage in sort
of being someone that people can look at
and say I like him because X even if X
isn't really describing that well let's
start to the Muller investigation the
Justice Department has said they're
ready auric signaled that they're ready
to release what they know on on this on
this deadline on this what are we saying
here what do you think is gonna come out
well we're not clear and when it's
actually gonna happen we certainly heard
rumors for a while about when this can
come out I mean technically robert
muller when he's done with his work he
has to turn over to the the justice
department the findings you know the
rationale behind the actions he took the
actions he didn't and then all the
different owner justice has to do is
tell congress here are the things we
kept him in from investigating that's
literally the bare minimum of what they
have to actually have to report publicly
there's a lot of political pressure on
them to release more than that and so
it'll be interesting to see what we
actually learn the House voted 420 to 0
this week a non-binding we should say to
release this report Lindsey Graham
blocked this in the Senate but I mean as
you say there's there's political
pressure what do you think we will see I
think it depends on what's in the report
right if for example there are
indications in the report that Donald
Trump is more culpable in some way than
he would like to admit he's gonna be
putting a lot of pressure on attorney
general Barr in the Department of
Justice to keep that close to the chest
however
there's going to be huge political
pressure the more that Donald Trump
withholds and the more the bar with
holds the more it's going to look like
they're hiding something so it also is
politically beneficial to the President
to put out there everything they
possibly can so that you can say look
I'm not hiding anything there's nothing
to suspect here we heard of from Mike
Pompeo he just missed news that Kim Jong
moon is looking into starting again
nuclear and missile testing what do we
know this is it's tricky right I mean
the North Koreans are in advantageous
position here which is that they had
worked to build and an intercontinental
ballistic missile and a nuclear weapon
that could be miniaturized and fit on
that missile it seems as though they've
done that and now they hold that card
and it's always been the pressure is
that the United States wants them to
give up those weapons but North Korea
recognizes this is their bargaining chip
and so they're not going to do that over
the short term and that's always been
the tension you know
a secretary state Pompeo knows more
about this than I do but that said it's
hard to see how North Korea is going to
give up their only playing card in this
game a little bump of the Washington
Post thanks very much